[Musique]
les quatre tiers de jean-luc aujourd'hui
que vient de rejoindre mon chéri et
c'est vrai qu'il fallait absolument
qu'on en parle de rihanna c'est vous
avez donné des infos effectivement bravo
à vous en tout cas j'espère que vous en
savez plus et c'est vraiment pour moi
c'est c'est une horreur naïl pujadas il
est il exceptionnel mais il va retrouver
du travail à mon avis très cela me tient
très vite avant on regardait d'adminium
etc- qui a dit david pujadas remplacé
par anne sophie lapix aux france de 20
heures 3 regardez il a faim croisons les
comme il le fait à chaque fois
guillaume tcd gala c'est pas mal allez
mon jean luc les questions 4/3 on
l'attend tous les mercredis cette
séquence c'est parti une question au
ballon c'est une question tout de suite
vu que sur ses parties bonjour je
m'appelle joël je suis très déçu du
départ de thierry moreau car c'est le
seul qui me faisait fantasmer que
comptez vous faire
parce que tous vos autres chroniqueurs
c'est vraiment des boudins
alors j'ai une info je vous le dis avant
qu'on continue c'est que emmanuel rien à
voir dans cette histoire de l'amy
pujadas vous le dis ils ont autre chose
de plus important à faire à traiter en
ce moment et ils vous le dit anne sophie
lapix n'est pas du tout a mis avec les
maquereaux donc ça n'a rien à voir
voilà donc je vous le dis donc on a
l'info et lien de mon ami bernard
montiel qui m'envoient sac et à la
montée qui a présenté les chiites et les
[ __ ] aimerait bien voilà c'est bernard
en tout cas on t'embrasse mon chéri et
ça me fait plaisir que tu nous regardes
mon jean luc question donc sur thierry
moreau pas exactement et je vous
comprends chers jeunes car moi aussi je
fantasme et secrètement sur thierry fois
je ne cache pas que la semaine dernière
ma libido s'était fondé d'un sur le coup
mais ce soir je voulais quand même
revenir sur ce moment si spécial de
l'émission unique en télévision d'un on
peut critiquer tpm paix mais ya que chez
nous qu'un chroniqueur peu partiez en
plein milieu du programme juste parce
qu'il est garé en double file
donc revenons sur cet historique 9 mai
au début tout avait bien commencé si
vous venez de lancer sa 254e nouvelle
rubrique depuis septembre le mercato des
chroniqueurs et on sait pas sûr qu'il
savait tomber même si avec le petit
teaser on avait tous deviné on a juste
pris six heures regarder on est allé
demander aux gens ce qu'ils pensaient de
lui dans la rue ou dell guy beauté
intelligence qui reste il un terrain
respect pour toi
[Musique]
nombreuses allées du club jean-michel un
pour lui avait pas de doute c'était
mathieu c'est juste après que sans le
vouloir il est devenu médium jean-michel
même s'ils se trouvaient encore sur la
personne vous allez voir c'est quand
même assez troublant bas il a été plutôt
d'accord du bar tout de suite après
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
jouer seddiki l'attention de façon
inattendue
on a un peu plus de lui ça va mais c'est
fou les bonnes personnes et la ds
en tout cas on est dans le 2.0 que quand
tu que tu parts est restée six tentes et
et mondain pour mathieu ça passe trop de
compassion virtuel chez lui alors je
vais pas trahir un secret mathieu a été
très affecté par le départ de pierrick
qu'il adorait ça tout le monde le sait
hahaha
mais quoi 500 ans assénait c'est vrai je
mets donc quand le lendemain gill a osé
dire que titi n'aurais pas dû partir
pendant l'émission
mathieu n'a pas supporté une seule
seconde qu'on puisse critiquer son ami
de toujours et au chant gilles très dur
encore une fois on ne suis pas dur c'est
que fils a quitté l'irak eu droit la
dirpa tout d'ailleurs midi avant la fin
de ce que tu es un garçon très digne qui
était plein d'émotions et il est pas
envie d'avoir des larmes en plateau
dokui laquelle passé sept ans avec des
gens qu'il a vu tous les jours
[Musique]
mettez la santé quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous posez beaucoup qui sont négatives
on est beaucoup moins mémoire derrière
moi complètement sa tablette non non non
je dirais oui mais à quoi
[Musique]
et à
[Applaudissements]
mais compris
on peut faire et ce à raison de deux
prix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien voilà j'arrive à faire la une de
télé 7 jours non on bouge et embrasse
thirith un ami j'ai déjeuné avec lui à
midi non c'est vrai non côté pilotes qui
ont leur bois servettiens on va dire le
vtt apprécié par tous bryce est vrai
pour ceux qui prendraient les missions
qu'on n'est pas décédé j'en ai tout va
bien donc tir était apprécié de tous et
surtout de capucine
ah oui déjà parce qu'il la faisait rire
mais aussi parce qu'il employait des
mots qu'elle ne connaissait pas en même
temps il y en a pas mal des moquées
connais pas toutes les compétitions de
before dans la rue oui exact je vous
signale et na pour mieux les mêmes
seront 16 et j'ai même fait choir
valérie benaïm par terre et c'était il
ya pas longtemps voire du verbe
permis régulier
merci sa voiture sa voix cassée une
magnifique introduction pour un nouveau
stop j'ai danse des séquences très
courtes cha cha ou alors ça tombe bien
parce que c'est le top gênante séquence
très crue
elles peuvent arriver que dans touche
pas à mon poste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quelque chose de sérieux c'est le
prix d'un vêtement connu mieux comme
entraîneur et caen 2 3 way
rosella tour de berne n'a pas tari
d'éloges
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
respecter mais naïma pourquoi pourquoi
vous n'avez pas été salée pour se
remettre de ces moments gênants mon
ex-femme préféré la semaine maintenant
on recevait des comédiens des mystères
de l'amour un match ou un cadeau quand
même les distribuer cyril hanouna mêlée
david mélé mec moi à chaque fois je vous
regarde tous les dimanches cela m'énerve
parce que vous êtes resté beau gosse
vous amuser toujours autant pas dans les
mystères de l'amour tout ça ben oui moi
je regarde tous les niveaux je suis là
où je rêve on regarde tous m'attend
c'était chouette ou comment on dirait
que cyril annonce fièrement qui ne
manque aucun épisode et mystères de
l'amour elle magnifique pub pour le
programme diffusé juste en face à savoir
gay ce maillage
[Rires]
deux fois pour l'émission moi je crois
que tu as a way et roddick s'est pas
vraiment le dimanche oui bien sûr
gassmann il me les envoie avant la
chenille les organes et combien les
derniers candidats ont beaucoup d'argent
bon heureusement si souvent la veille à
la baisse sur tous les dimanches de la
veille et 18e
oui on va les inédits c'est à partir de
19 heures 10 10
alors ça arrive dix minutes à la manche
ou heureusement cyril a souvent la main
plus heureuse comme quand il a lancé la
semaine dernière la merguez des vacances
je rappelle le principe une merguez
vient chez vous et vous offre un voyage
c'est sympa mais en y réfléchissant bien
c'est jean michel maire qui est quand
même la réflexion la puissance et de la
semaine bon bah on va filmer
ah oui bah il faut pas perdre vos biens
tout le quartier
[Applaudissements]
je vais dormir
beaucoup de gens me demandent souvent
pourquoi cyril faire entrer des nouveaux
chroniqueurs dans l'équipe si c'est
parce que les anciens sont plus sous
garantie et bien ce que vous dire la
vérité c'est pour deux raisons 1
pour éviter que les missions au rhône et
deux pour pc puisse refaire des blagues
qui ne marchaient plus avec les anciens
vous allez comprendre en voyant la
différence entre une chroniqueuse
historique
même valérie benaïm et un nouveau masque
kenny
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
lourdeur c'est pour ça c'est juste pour
ça vient ça 8 en chine l'unique a aussi
trouvé sa place dans l'équipe en
devenant le complice de matthieu
delormeau
mais alors regardez vous allez voir
quand on veut faire un mauvais coup et
isabelle morini-bosc bas l'autre est là
pour lui prêter main forte et très bien
organisée
[Musique]
non
les caprices
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je connais tous nos maux
mon dada
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien que derniers sésames qui veut pas
de code
je croyais que tu faisais avec ton
propre portable mais pas du banc pas
drôle banon va pas s'envoler et equis
pour rien tu crois que personne n'y ait
envoyé à ses propres contacts ip des
étoiles est un peu et c'est intelligent
on sait en tout cas depuis qu'il est
dans tes pmp isabelle a dû faire face à
tellement d'attaqués que maintenant dès
que quelque chose comme ans et craint le
pire
bon là vous allez voir elle a été loin
dans la paranoïa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en rêvais
sérieux
la salle jean taille basse cette
personne est folle comment ils auraient
du sperme sur lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours une émission familiale là
bas c'est sûr qu'avec toi t'as pas dû
top depuis de cinq minutes au moins la
charité ça fait une belle transition
pour passer à tous qu'on n'aurait pas
voulu voir là dedans et on va commencer
et on commence par la joie de gilles
verdez découvrant que dans chacun veut
prendre sa patte c'est le singe qui sent
son doigt qui gardait son titre serait
joué que ça c'est déjà étrange mais
qu'en plus c'était déguisée en
infirmière
tu sais quoi
[Applaudissements]
non à 12 h
e
vous pouvez répondre à son amour je sais
pas j'ai envie de te prendre dans mes
bras
ce qui est pour moi tu te calmes pas tu
vas ce sera ta première et la dernière
et non je le dis de ne pas parler entre
nous pendant voilà qu'on aime jean luc
azoulay aujourd'hui côte à côte face à
la wii janvier qu'il roulait pas notre
réponse suivante 6 15 mai pour y
remédier elle adore voir une vraie
followers mais non
voilà je vous dis on va y arriver je la
trouve
oui à une série télévisée
ghoulam a host of cards on sent pas
français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
là
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
les autres il est très chaud break ont
la bonne et due forme ou jean-luc la
boîte mail
m